good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this extraordinary meeting of
stratford-upon-avon district council
cabinet first of all can I ask for
apologies for absence please policies
from cash the saintly leader of the
council and also from Council of Morris
house thank you for that I think it's
only fair just to mention about
councillor st. in seven years this is
only the second cabinet meeting but he's
actually missed four those are not aware
chris has been suffering with a knee
problem which is further exactly at
excavated excuse me over the weekend
we've the Shakespeare birthday
celebrations because he insisted in
walking everywhere coupled with the fact
is the heat was very very nice for some
people could affect other people in a
different way this resulted but by the
time that we got to the Crowne Plaza
Hotel Chris was unwell
he ended up being hospitalized his knee
problem is quite serious at the moment
and we're just waiting to see when he's
going to be released actually from
hospital that's all I was telling that
thank you
right moving on to the real purpose
while we're here today which is to
consider a paper on delivery of
affordable housing this will then
hopefully if we agree to it today will
then go forward to full council tomorrow
for deliberation because I therefore ask
councillor Peter Richards to introduce
Thank You chairman members you will no
doubt recall in October span this
cabinet agreed to further work on a
strategic business case for a wholly
owned company by this council to be run
by this council this is the next stage
of that work so in front of you is that
strategic business case what we are
seeking for today is the approval of the
strategic objectives which are laid out
on page 2 of the report I don't propose
to read them all but will if members
want me to and then for the cabinet to
authorize the establishment of a housing
delivery company subject to further
approval of a detailed business case and
then as a third point to agree the
creation of any further companies as
required in order to support the housing
delivery company I will leave it at that
for time being an answer any questions
members may have colleagues any
questions
councillor Morse
I have no concerns about this and I
support it fully I just wondered yet
whether we'd established yet whether we
can use money from developers within
this company
it's the council using money from
developers for off-site financial
contributions
Cancellara Keith that is very much on
our agenda we have a new sister on the
fourth house in working group we have as
a group put that to our officers I
haven't actually had a report back on
that yet so I will follow it up and my
understanding is yes that is that that
can be done
clearly the s106 determines how that
money may be spent and specific I
believe you're talking about the
affordable housing element of that so I
can't see that being a problem counselor
Barnes
going on from that I've got a number of
abilities which it's getting half a
million pounds because people had his
poor affordable homes and I think we're
pleased that he's moving forward what we
don't really want it but there was a
meeting between Carla and myself
Kenneth Carville and my brain went about
doing it building affordable homes when
builders couldn't sell I was against
that but a foolish support what we're
trying to do thank you for that
that's right consume thanks Gemma I
think the aims are very laudable I
believe though that's not necessarily
entirely affordable homes market homes
could come within this proposal but I
question whether or not creating a
separate corporate entity is the best
way forward my experience of similar
things which are unrelated to what has
been the core activity of an
organization is to create a joint
venture with someone who has specialism
in this particular market I think in
this instance it would obviously have to
be a Housing Association
it has considerable advantages you
remove a lot of management aggravation
you've then got to think about this
subsidiary within the umbrella of the
District Council headed by a chief
executive we've recently got rid of that
distinction in the district do find a
bit contradictory what's the reporting
lines what's the responsibilities I
presume the chief executive would report
to one of the senior members of the
current district council organization
the general principle of creating
something of this nature is to me good I
would certainly suggest that it is
referred to have a look as to what can
be created with one of the housing
associations it is their market they
know at left right and center
they know the management principles from
our point of view we may have land
assets which are useful to put in and
that hasn't considerable benefit for us
and indeed for anyone we employ their
relationship with it's not an easy thing
to manage we found that ourselves that's
why when the opportunity came along to
dispose off the housing stock we took it
and I believe it has worked very well I
think something can be done with this
objective but my attitude would be on a
joint-venture basis with one of the
housing associations as it happens
affordable development in our district
which occurred on the berming Road which
are the property I believe was one time
the office of the District Council that
has been developed on a rental basis in
conjunction with orbit by a local
organization and it gives the management
expertise away from our own experience I
suggest that we do have a look at this
alternative before we carry it forward
I believe in management terms it is the
best solution Thanks Thank You
councillor ikenson
councillor Richards there's a lot in
that that I need to decipher let me take
the management and CEO structure first
very clearly the recommendation to does
lay out the what is being suggested here
and that is subject to the approval of
further detail business case which would
include governance arrangements for that
company so that is to be to be
determined in the fullness of time in
terms of delivery alongside you know our
P's that's the wrong phraseology is now
I'm looking at for this register
providers that could be part of the
delivery function and in setting up
these business
there's this individual company we can
enter into those sort of joint ventures
the key element one of the key elements
of this it's a the control that the
council will have over the delivery of
the housing and therefore housing units
and you were right that it is market
housing as well as affordable but it
also allows the council to gain an
income which is one of the key drivers
of this that we are able to generate an
income to make our council more
sustainable for the future you mentioned
income that's what of course a joint
venture would generate I think the
management factor in such a situation is
better for us and trying to manage our
own corporate entity I've seen it before
I know one come here I run I said the
aim must be to create a profit of a
million pound a month we did that for
the joint folders that was distributed
5050 and you can you can manage that I
think you've got the benefit then of
complete independence managing our
housing stock is not an easy job yet you
have got a financial gain particularly
where we have the opportunity to place
some of our land assets into a managed
organization which knows this market we
have a double whammy in that instance
not not just a single benefit
yeah Riley I haven't had the experience
of managing to joint ventures where our
relationship we provided the money and
also certain other factors the others
had the marketing lead or selling their
products it does work well on I hope
some edits to the recommendation maybe
to look at the alternative which I'm
preaching thank you mean we're only here
to be able to pass it on to full counsel
I'm sure that will come up in the debate
tomorrow anyway I've got some other
speakers before I come back to you
councillor Richards customers
that's exactly what I'm preaching Canton
riches thanks Jeff and this one's been
flying around for quite a while I think
sort of 18 months or so ago when we
first kind of flowed to this idea so I
think to get to this point is really
good the paper is quite tight in so much
that the business case including the
governance of the company has already
mentioned is going to come back to
cabinet for a second round of approval I
don't see why we shouldn't be doing this
and I think we should thank you as an
organisation but it has the capacity
fantastic and why is it fantastic
because the council kept a tight grip on
it
I'm ensured that things were running
away that was acceptable to our
residents
in fact as a student I was actually sent
to Stratford district council from
Birmingham Pali to see how
[Music]
[Music]
thank you don't forget
thank you I've been involved in this
since the beginning seen it actually
evolved experience elsewhere we've been
on a number of visits to other
organizations that have done this it's
actually now increasingly common for
councils to have one of these companies
and certainly one in particular we
visited there is no doubt about it
having a good CEO makes a real
difference and I think now we're in a
position where really we just need to
get on with it and deliver it thank you
calibrators want you i till being on
this working party and therefore seen
this progress it is something which is a
key priority for the council it's
something where we can help certain
sections of our community and help at
the lower end of the market for them to
succeed in their own family base as I
said the debate will actually carry on
at the full council tomorrow
and if there are no other speakers
therefore I turn ask you to turn to page
and one note the recommendations to
council to approve this to TV conjecture
to set out in the report secondly to
authorize a cabinet to establish a
housing delivery company subject to its
approval but further detailed business
case which will include a governmental
agency for that company and thirdly to
agree to the creation of further
companies as required in order to
support the housing delivery company
subject to the prior approval of
individual business cases by the Cabinet
do we agree thank you
moving on to an extra item that's been
snuck in to the agenda this is the
Warmington and a skirt parish plan page
plans do not have to go through the same
process as neighbourhood plan does but
it does need to be agreed through the
cabinet before we take that decision I
will open it up for debate
councillor fielding the offices of the
District Council and they are satisfied
with the document I would like to be in
a position where they can distribute it
at their AGM in May so they are very
content thank you for that colleagues
any comments counselor
Thank You chairman having read this
report I would just like to say it is a
really excellent parish planets probably
one of the best I've seen and I've got
absolutely no problem in adopting this
this document thank you that I would say
I think it's very very encouraging after
a small community that 86% of the people
took part in giving their views and
thoughts which is very encouraging I
also know what the ward members had to
say about it and I would hope therefore
on that particular basis that we could
go straight to the recommendation which
is on page 101 which is asking that the
Warmington and asketh perish plan
attached to Appendix 1 to be adopted as
a material consideration when
determining planning applications in
accordance with the policies of the
adopted core strategy and it is an
important source of local information
councillor richest probably a very quick
one chair don't we normally congratulate
the community or the parish
you took the words out of my mouth I was
ghost talking to us that we do actually
write back to the said people thank them
for their hard work and congratulate
them on an absolutely superb parish plan
agreed and finally any urgent business
innovation business Chairman I declare
the meeting closed